all right so M Night fans are in for
another Twist and Turn psychological
Horror Story with his latest knock at
the cabin four strangers one cabin the
signs are all there but yeah we're gonna
be breaking this thing down for y'all
what the ending means a whole lot of
symbolism and of course our reaction and
review of the movie and the mandatory M
Night Cameo all sorts of heavy spoilers
in this one so a huge thank you for
clicking this I'm your host Jared now
let's get into knock at the cabin
yeah foreign
[Music]
opens on a family of three on vacation
at a remote Cabin in the Woods as we're
introduced to a young Wen catching
grasshoppers it's funny because she's
kind of like categorizing these into our
little notebook showing that she's an
inquisitive little girl she looks up
though as a stranger walks out of the
woods towards her and this is Dave
Batista's Leonard after the two play a
game of back and forth questions
Leonard's friends follow behind and he
tells when his heart hurts because he
has to make a terrible decision that day
bam we are right into the home invasion
portion of this movie as Leonard and his
group try to calmly reason and discuss
what is about to happen but have to kind
of use Force against daddy Andrew and
daddy Eric the couple is tied up after
Eric hits his head resulting in a
concussion the poor strangers line up
with their makeshift weapons and Leonard
tells them that they need to make the
ultimate sacrifice to stop the
apocalypse and one of the three must
willingly give their life to stop it by
the hand of another what no obviously
Eric Andrew Wen hell even me was like
what's the catch what what's the twist
here the four calmly introduced
themselves Leonard a school teacher
Sabrina a nurse who spent most of her
life savings getting there but like like
how she she only drove a car you're a
nurse you should be getting whatever
Adrian a cook who has a young son and
Redmond Harry Potter's best friend they
all claim they had shared visions of the
end of the world Terminator style which
guided them together and led them to
this remote cabin so at this point this
seems like a random encounter but the
couple specifically Andrew believes that
it's a targeted attack on the same-sex
couple Leonard the leader assures him
that that's not the case and that every
time they say no to their demands the
four of them will release a different
plague upon the people of the world
essentially judging them against
sounding like some January 6th 4chan
poppycock the three refuse resulting in
Redmond being the first to give his life
after their no response while Redmond
states that a plague will be released
anyone lives Eric's season out of the
ordinary bright light behind Redmond but
thinks nothing of it they turn on the
television to see a massive earthquake
has occurred sending a giant Johnny
Tsunami barreling the West Coast taking
thousands of lives okay I'll bite what
the hell is actually going on here
Leonard assures them that everything
they are saying is true they must just
believe them but it's pretty hard to
believe when they claim the visions of
these so-called nightmares just came to
them in the middle of the night a few
more personal Snippets of the four
mysterious people's lives how they met
and flashbacks of Eric and Andrew the
flashback showed the hardships of the
pair as a couple adopting when having to
lie about the relationship and driving
to to the cabin only hours before Andrew
and Eric still in disbelief this series
of question answer unaliving plague
continues with Adrian sacrificing
herself resulting in the second plague a
virus called X9 affecting thousands of
children when distracts Leonard and
Sabrina allowing Andrew to break free
grabbing his gun from the vehicle and
then shooting Sabrina as she tries to
attack him again they say no to
Leonard's demands and soon the newscast
on the television showcases hundreds of
airplanes across the planet falling from
the sky resulting in again thousands of
deaths Andrew still skeptical of
everything urging that they are in some
weird ass cult the broadcasts are fake
and again claiming that this is a
targeted attack when he remembers being
assaulted years ago in a bar by none
other than Redmond things are a bit
squirrely now because yeah there's got
to be a catch right but Eric is starting
to believe in Leonard nerd and claims he
saw a vision of a glowing figure when he
saw the bright light earlier in the film
Leonard being the last one again asks
them if they are willing but again
receives a no he urges them that they
will only have minutes to choose after
his passing or they will be destined to
walk the scorched land after Earth is
destroyed just the three of them
lightning begins to rain down after
Leonard's passing Eric and Andrew still
don't know what to do because is any of
this actually real but Eric steps in
saying he believes there's a reason he
saw the glowing figure and the four were
actually The Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse embodying the essential
components of humanity malice nurturing
healing and guidance as Andrew then
shoots Eric Andrew goes to when hiding
in the treehouse as they watch burning
trees fall on the cabin destroying it
all as then the skies clear up and the
lightning stops the pair make it to
Leonard's truck discovering everything
that the group said was true meaning
that all of the visions and plagues had
to be true too right they drive into the
nearby Village seen a diner full of
people watching newscasts from around
the world covering the destruction that
just took place the belief is real even
one of the waitresses can be heard
talking to a loved one on the phone
expressing their love for them the final
bit sees when and Andrew get back into
the truck and Boogie Shoes the same song
that the three listen to on their way to
the cabin plays on the radio the two
turn it off and then back on wondering
if everything was a coincidence or if
they should believe that it's a sign
from a higher power as they drive off
into the sunset all right so uh yeah
there's no big twist No Big M Night
Shyamalan he was dead the whole time
reveal so uh apologies for anyone who
wanted their brain exploded but there is
a lot of symbolism here that clearly
alludes to this encompassing religion
belief those who don't believe in a
higher power rather chalking it up as a
coincidence and the second coming of
Christ this is pretty much hinted at
throughout the film for example the
couple thinks it's Jehovah Witnesses at
the door originally they are
fear-mongered into believing like some
religions do about heaven and hell
there's a mural of Jesus playing
basketball when adopting when Sabrina
mentions that she hadn't been to church
in years because it was boring and that
people should believe in something
bigger than themselves but it's very
much hammered home with the four
horsemen the plagues and the impending
apocalypse sure it's revealed close to
the end of the film specifically that
each of the four people embody Aid going
back to you know the malice the nurture
healing and guidance but Shyamalan did
some clever costuming because the color
of their shirts reflect the traits
before the movie reveals who they
actually are redmen conveying malice was
wearing red which typically means anger
aggression or warning also historically
red was quote here the first color named
after white and black symbolizing him
biting the dust first also if you look
at the Blackboard in the background it's
kind of teased Adrian was nurturing
because she was a cook and blue is a
calming relaxing trustworthy color that
is reliable for support Sabrina being
healing she was a nurse and yellow
affects the logical part of the brain
stimulating perception and lastly
Leonard was guidance being a teacher and
a coach with white or light pink I don't
know I might be a little bit colorblind
but it's a mix of self-reflection warmth
and compassion so Mr Knight good job on
you with those colors anyway Eric Andrew
and Wen were specifically picked for
this sacrifice because they were full of
love and Purity in a world that
otherwise was not now Andrew was very
much on the outskirts of things having
selfish ideas and such they had all been
through prejudices though deformities
treated like outcasts but remained
unbreakable and Eric's Vision was what
truly ended it all he finally believed
it's almost like a scene is believing
approach like all the other four that
received Visions from The Four Horsemen
Eric instead saw God maybe Jesus a deity
of some sort or even the fabled fifth
Horseman which is said to bring about
rebirth and grow a healthier future this
is why he slowly started to believe in
something greater than himself and he
could see Andrew and Wen living the
dreams that they always wanted to in the
future even the grasshoppers in the
opening sequence symbolized patience and
a leap of faith that they all had to
take in order to stop everything
I I could be dead wrong here but I think
Knight was going on how we need to
change the way we act to save the world
and lastly the Boogie Shoes song at the
end is just just toying with everything
we just saw the belief that we should or
shouldn't have was it a coincidence or
was it a sign from a greater power was
the entire series of events coincidence
or a greater sign what exactly is The
Happening Here I want to say Andrew and
Wen believe in a greater power telling
them that Eric is now in a better place
watching after them but for everyone at
the diner coincidence might still be
what they believe now knock at the cabin
which by the way knock that like And
subscribe Button as it helps keep those
pesky Horsemen away and the spoilers
flowing but yeah this is uh roughly
based on the 2018 novel The Cabin at the
End of the World by Paul Tremblay I
briefly glanced through a summary of
this before and I would say say that a
majority of this kind of follows the
same story beats different characters
doing different things here or there but
two of the biggest differences between
the novel and the movie is that when
does not pass away in the movie I know
that this was a big moment in the novel
and the ending is not left ambiguous you
know like the novel M Night mentioned in
an interview that he actually called
Tremblay about the changes that he was
going to make and surprisingly Tremblay
said the M night's ending was his second
choice for the novel he was split so uh
the the more you know I I thought knock
at the cabin was fine I was intrigued by
where everything was going whether or
not the events were actually happening
and real but revealing the truth like
Midway in the film kinda took away that
Big M Night twist that were usually you
know banking on again the story was fine
a little heavy-handed on the religious
metaphors throughout and why certain
connections were even there like Rupert
being the guy in the bar why and
honestly kinda had like a cabin in the
woods feel at the end I'd give it like a
low 7 out of ten but the technical side
of things is where this movie shines
this might be Batista's best performance
very subdued and quiet reminded me of
his bit part from Blade Runner 2049 so
he was definitely the standout and some
of the camera work that they did was
hella cool like Batista is using this
weapon at some point and it like follows
the trajectory as he like cranks it back
and then goes for a hit oh an M nights
Cameo was so ridiculously dumb I
couldn't not love it basically they are
flipping through TV channels you know
looking at these newscast apocalypse and
he's just on one selling air fryers in
an infomercial for like a solid 15
seconds anyway I kind of do wish that
some of this was just a big elaborate
goof and they were tricking them but uh
you know whatever the story was fine
anyway I'd love to hear your thoughts on
knock at the cabin was this one of M
night's better films in the last few
decades or is his shtick getting old and
I'll let you know we're currently
running a competition giving away three
copies of wakanda Forever on the 15th of
February and all you gotta do to get a
chance of winning this is like this
video make sure to subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment with
your thoughts on knock at the cabin down
below we picked the comments at random
at the end of every single month in the
winners of last month are on screen
right now so if that's you message us on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch be sure to check
out some of our other videos right over
there click one just do it knock knock
knock on one of those videos but with
that out of the way thank you for your
constant support I've been Jared I'll
see in the next one take care and peace